Do you use the silver side up or the black side up on the grounding pad that came with the
rife. That's a great question. You want to be putting the silver side against your skin,
the black side away from you. If you look in your rife tutorial, there should be each of you
should have received not only the binder that we sent you that has all of the basic rife
information, but there should have been a little booklet depending upon the the generation of the
of the rife machine that you have. It's either an F117 or an F122 and those are the two
different types of generators that have currently been put out by true rife. When you open up
that little pamphlet or booklet in there, it will give you some directions on how to utilize
the grounding mat and they will be able to reiterate for you exactly the side to use it.
So if you're going to be sitting on it and you want to put it as a chair underneath you,
you just want to make sure that the black side is facing away from you and that you're sitting on the
gray side. If you're going to be keeping it on the ground underneath your feet, you'd want to do the
same thing black side away from you, set that set your feet on top of it.